the morning
my name is Clinton Jones and I love
creating photoreal 3D environments I
draw inspiration from the places I've
been around the world and the
experiences I've had that shaped me as
an artist
recreating personal memories allows me
to not only revisit those memories and
feelings but more importantly they offer
a unique and personal angle to create my
art from it's almost a shortcut to
developing your style and artistic voice
so in this video I'd love to show you
how I'm utilizing 3D software to bring
my latest trip to life in the hopes of
inspiring you to create your own unique
experiences and since creating quickly
is so important in today's day and age I
want to show you how I'm creating these
speed environments in one day's time
shout outs to Aces for sponsoring this
video stick around to learn all about
the aces Pro Arts Studio Book Pro OLED
laptop and how it can keep you creative
on the go now if we're gonna create this
scene quickly it's crucial We Gather the
right reference a few months back I
attended the third annual camp mograph a
yearly multi-day Meetup where 3D artists
Educators and Industry professionals
step away from their computers and into
nature to learn laugh and relax together
as friends and family since Camp was
held on the beach this year we gathered
together on the warm sand to experience
a glorious sunset together every evening
the images and videos from this triple
act as my creative cheat sheet and give
me everything I need to pack our scene
full of sentimental detail I'll begin
creating any powerful free program
called Unreal Engine 5. you can download
the software in the description along
with a number of other useful tools and
resources but I'll start with the game
project file in a blank scene with RTX
enabled to navigate we can hold right
click and use the was and D Keys q and E
to Crane up and down and the slider on
the top right will control camera
sensitivity with an object selected
spacebar Cycles between position
rotation and scale gizmos control
backtick will switch between local and
World orientation F will snap your
viewport to any selected object and the
G key will show or hide viewport icons
but where do we start I want to lay out
the main building blocks of our scene
first mainly the ocean the dock and our
sky as well as our camera angle now if
you've been watching my videos for a
while now you know I'm all about getting
to the overall Vibe as fast as humanly
possible so we can spend time on the
details later so let's sketch out our
scene by adding an ocean by first
ensuring the water plug-in is enabled
and let's create a landscape object
first for our ocean to live on let's
switch to the landscape panel and create
a landscape and search for ocean in the
place actors window which is where you
can create lights cameras volumes and
various other objects like water and
drag it out into our scene but for now
let's lock in the next biggest element
the lighting now you can use the default
lighting setup in unreal but I'm using a
plugin called Ultra Dynamic Sky it's
incredibly versatile and extremely easy
to use so let's adjust the volumetric
cloud amount time of day slider and fog
amount to get our lighting to the 90
Mark to add light shafts I'll search for
them in the details panel crank the
light shaft slider to make sure the
effect is working then dial it back for
a subtle look we can adjust our sun
radius for a more dramatic effect
tweak the sky saturation and overall
intensity if needed now let's add our
main subject next the old wooden dock
since speed is my main goal I'm
utilizing this asset pack on the epic
games Marketplace and kit bash the dock
based on my reference images from cam
to make final tweaking easier I'll
select every doc asset and hit Ctrl G to
group them and now that we have a
subject we can finally set up our camera
by searching for cine camera in the
place actors window dragging it out
right clicking and selecting pilot
camera choose your favorite aspect ratio
lock the camera's Focus to the dock and
line up your shot remember it's a waste
of time to work on things the camera
can't see so it's crucial to set up our
camera angle early on in order to
further focus our creative efforts and
since I want to export an animated scene
and ensure my camera stays locked in
this position I need to create a
timeline or a sequence as it's called an
Unreal Engine let's drag our camera
inside and add keyframes to the position
and rotation to ensure it's locked in
place and in case we move it it'll
automatically snap back don't forget to
set your frame rate to 24 for that nice
filmic look and set your preferred
timeline duration and to finally lock in
our look I'll create a post-process
volume from the place actors window
which can use to control the overall
look of your scene just be sure to look
for Unbound and check Infinite extent
now I like to make subtle color shifts
gamma tweaks add vignette and film grain
as well as control or render settings
like changing our Reflection from Lumen
to Ray Trace which is crucial for a
scene like this
now I'd consider this about 80 complete
I'm generally happy with our lighting
camera and composition and we got here
in no time at all so let's move on to
the next most important element the
crowd atop Our Deck using miximo a free
animated character Library by Adobe I'm
able to grab a handful of different
characters performing different actions
by dragging the characters into the
sequencer and selecting their animation
you can drag out their handles for an
infinitely looping character and since
we're dealing with silhouetted people
from a distance you'll never notice the
duplicate stock characters that fill up
this dock now for my favorite part
adding the custom details that will make
this scene special and specific to the
time we all spent together in Silver
Beach Virginia it's the story element
that makes your art significant so I'll
break each added element down in order
of importance to the piece starting with
this tower that was so unique to this
location so let's kit Bash one from
assets I found on cgtrader.com and get
it out there I don't even need to
texture it since it's only seen in
silhouette and to connect this Tower to
the rest of our scene I'll add another
one way off into the distance and a
smaller antenna attached to our dock
it's what take makes it from a
recreation to an artistic interpretation
I did the same thing with both of these
pieces of art referenced from my trips
in Newfoundland Canada but now the image
looks empty on the right side so I made
this old fishing net in Cinema 4D by
locking up the vertices of a sweeped
spline and enabling rope Dynamics from
there I made this low poly seaweed piece
and cloned it across an identical spline
a few feet higher with a cloner object
and random effector I gave the seaweed a
cloth tag and hit play the dynamic rope
catches some of the seaweed on its way
down giving us the perfect look just add
some bamboo supports from the mega scans
Library which come free with unreal 5
and we're starting to balance things out
back in Cinema 4D I'll quickly model a
buoy duplicate it across our mid ground
and subtly animate them up and down in
sequencer to fake that bobbing on the
surface of the watered look since I know
I'll create a nighttime version of this
scene which I'll walk you through soon
I'll create some string lights to draw
the AI to our dock in c4d I'll use the
same Dynamic spline technique on a sweep
spline to set up our lights model a
basic bulb and use a cloner set to
object mode to duplicate it across our
scene I'll export an fbx and bring it
back into unreal making sure to uncheck
combined meshes that way I can light up
the bulbs only and for the final touch
during our last sunset together at camp
mograph we experienced this special
moment the timing was perfect and I had
to add it in so I modeled a low poly
kayak in cinema animated the paddles
with grayscale gorilla's signal plug-in
which gives you full loopable control
over any attribute from there I created
a basic character in Das 3D a free
character generator software brought him
into c4d Auto rigged him using daz's
importer and animated his hands to match
the paddles I baked the single Loop down
to an Olympic file brought it in unreal
as a geometry cache and animated the
loop across the Horizon with sequencer
now I love taking my hobbies on the go
and when it comes to 3D art and video
production the Asus Pro Art Studio Book
Pro OLED laptop has me covered and it's
packed with Hardware to make creating
scenes like this possible from anywhere
in the world first off it's equipped
with a gorgeous color accurate 16 inch
4K OLED display which guarantees true
black values and the perfect accuracy we
need when dialing in our look it comes
loaded with an Intel I9 processor an
Nvidia RTX A3000 with 12 gigabytes of
vram and a flexible memory configuration
with up to 64 gigs of physical RAM it
also ships with a 4 terabyte SSD drive
for quick file transfer and storage for
all your applications now a really cool
feature I dig on this Pro art laptop is
the Asus dial which lets you control
things like brightness and volume on the
fly but also allows for mapping of
custom inputs like brush size saturation
or layer opacity the pro art Creator Hub
lets you customize performance color
screen calibration and the Asus dial
settings the laptop's been a fantastic
to my 3D workflow for on-the-go
creativity and it's a wonderful
professional grade laptop for any
Creator so if you guys are interested in
checking out asus's Pro art laptop for
your on-the-go creativity 3D modeling
video production click that link in the
description it really helps me out
thanks for your time everybody let's hop
back in to the art
so why stop with just the sunset scene
let's have fun and experiment to see how
far we can really push our scene for the
night version it's almost as easy as
moving the time of day slider until we
see the moon and we can dial in its
position with the moon offset settings
crank the moon radius just a bit mess
with the moon phase to get that
copywritten look and tweak the texture
brightness to make it a little bit
brighter now it's super important to
give yourself time to explore the
various settings as you never know what
you'll find and where your art can go
let's light up our dock since we added
those string lights earlier I'll apply
this basic emissive material instance to
our light bulbs but this isn't enough
the emissive lights don't actually light
up our dock so I'll create a rectangle
light from our place actors window
adjust its size and place it just above
our string lights but I want to see the
shape of the light in the fog and the
only way to get that look is by ensuring
our fog inside of ultra Dynamic sky is
set to volumetric only then can we crank
the volumetric intensity in our rec
light settings to see our volumetric
light shafts let's create a basic sphere
from the place actors window add a red
emissive light and place them atop each
antenna for a touch of sweet sweet
detail and that completes our night
version but what about a super foggy
version
so years back I explored the Mount
Wilson Observatory with my good friend
young and when we got to the top we were
greeted with an amazing sight massive
Towers peering out from the thick layer
of fog now let's see if we can get that
same look with ultra Dynamic Sky
selected let's change the time of day
add some clouds and take the fog slider
up and definitely adjust your exposure
if need be let's search for fog in the
UDS details panel and if we increase the
base fog density and foggy density
contribution we're getting close but now
our Tower is gone but check this out if
we tweak the foggy height fog fall off
slider we'll start to get that effect
we're going for finally I'll hide
everyone except a lone character now I'm
gonna be honest with you I almost
couldn't figure out how to fix this ugly
extra bright reflection on the water so
if you're getting the same issue it
likely has to do with the absorption
settings on the water material so I just
set the absorption to black and it fixed
things write up so much better and with
that we have completed all three
versions of our scene but to export them
and call it a day right now would be a
disservice to your time and your art
it'd be like making a song you're proud
of but not taking the time to mix it
properly so we need to do a bit of color
grading and add some post-process
effects to truly bring our art through
the finish line and I'll be doing this
with a free non-linear editor called
DaVinci Resolve I'll start with the
color grade by working in the shadows
the mid-tones and the Highlight values
first then in another layer or node in
DaVinci since it's node based I'll apply
any color or saturation tweaks next I'll
create a node to add vignette another
for Bloom which really helps me pop out
the deck in our night scene and don't
forget to blur your CG renders Just a
Touch because perfectly sharp footage
doesn't really exist and finally I'll
add film grain last on top of everything
else you can use DaVinci's built-in
grain but I like to use grain from a
pack called gorilla grain set to Overlay
for best results after adding a bit of
music with Paul stretch and Ableton Live
our very personal unique environment is
complete
tonight
if you want to follow this tutorial step
by step that's totally fine it's what we
all have to do to learn these programs
but I'll encourage you to also use your
personal trips and experiences as a
jumping off points to push yourself
really helped me find my style and I
hope it helps you too
this is the first video in a small
series of speed environment breakdowns
so feel free to subscribe so you don't
miss those as well as my next big
Community challenge in February of 2023.
my name is Clinton Jones keep learning
keep growing and I'll see you guys soon
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]